est scandaleux dans le scandale
républicain d'areva avec ura mines je
rappelle le titre de votre livre qui est
l'homme à qui en savait beaucoup trop
aux éditions massot pour revoir cette
émission sur rtl france point tva
bientôt sur rt france merci beaucoup
[Musique]
chaque jour en politique des milliers de
parties d'échecs sont joués mais les
règles ne sont pas toujours respectées
les couleurs changent de camp
les pions prennent la place des rois
de films stratégies peuvent porter des
résultats inattendus
[Musique]
un coup décisif ne fait que repousser la
victoire
[Musique]
je suis l'ex maire et chaque semaine
dans l'échiquier mondial nous
analyserons les coups les plus complexes
du jeu politique internationale
à bientôt sur rt france
[Musique]
nouvelle frappe aérienne des états unis
cette fois à kaboul le pentagone évoque
une frappe défensive de drones pour
supprimer une menace imminente la cible
un véhicule chargé d'explosifs qui
serait lié à la branche locale de
l'organisation terroriste état islamique
le jour du retrait des troupes
américaines approchent joe biden avait
prévenu du risque d'un nouvel attentat
après celui de jeudi près de l'aéroport
de kaboul il est leur rendait hommage
aux treize soldats américains mort lors
de cet attentat tout à l'heure
israélienne sur la bande de gaza ce
dimanche une réponse aux balles deux
incendiaires lancées depuis l'enclavé
palestinienne sous blocus israélien
depuis près de 15 ans l'armée
israélienne d'avoir ciblé un complexe
militaire du hamas
[Musique]
politique en allemagne avec un premier
grand débat télévisé ce soir pour les
trois prétendants à la succession
d'angela merkel à un mois des
législatives
armin laschet tu le candidat
conservateur du cd ou semblait en bonne
position pour l'emporter mais les
sociaux démocrates du spd avec à sa tête
olaf scholz sont désormais en tête des
intentions de vote
[Musique]
et
bonsoir et bienvenue si vous nous
rejoignez sur rt france nous sommes
certains d'avoir atteint la cible
annonce du pentagone tout à l'heure les
états unis ont effectué une nouvelle
frappe aérienne de drones contre un
véhicule chargé d'explosifs
un véhicule qui appartiendraient à la
branche afghane du groupe terroriste
état islamique plutôt une explosion
avait été entendue à kaboul la menace
d'un nouvel attentat après celui qui a
eu lieu jeudi près de l'aéroport était
imminente selon washington
et aux côtés de son épouse joe biden a
assisté à une cérémonie durant laquelle
son été reçu les dépouilles des treize
soldats américains morts lors de cet
attentat suicide cela s'est passé sur la
base militaire de dover à 2h de
washington plus tôt le président des
états unis avait rencontré les familles
des soldats décédés avant de se
recueillir devant leurs dépouilles dans
un hommage solennel
et alors que le retrait des troupes
américaines touche à sa fin à kaboul la
tension est maximale avec la prise de
pouvoir des talibans les habitants de la
capitale qui n'ont pas réussi à quitter
le pays sont résignés d'autres veulent
croire que les talibans ont changé les
insurgés eux s'évertue à rompre avec
l'image de terreur mourad gaz dief
envoyé spécial pour rt internationale
s'est rendu auprès des habitants de
kaboul il est aussi allé à la rencontre
des talibans regardez
vers les choses choquantes dalbade le
choc initial causés par la prise de
pouvoir des talibans s'estompe peu à peu
les gens sortent dans les rues ils n'ont
plus aussi peur qu'avant les magasins
qui ouvre cependant on est toujours dans
le flou les gens ne sont pas certains de
ce qu'il va se passer désormais il
ignore quand les banques vont couvrir
ils ne savent pas ce que les talibans ce
que ces nouveaux talibans vont faire
les talibans d'aujourd'hui prétendent
être très différents des talibans des
années 90 la dernière fois que leur
combat tongs et kaboul ils se sont
comportés comme des sauvages les
brutalités et les exécutions se sont
multipliés
d'abord nous avons tous eu peur que ce
soit comme en 1996 quand les talibans
sont arrivés au pouvoir mais d'après ce
que nous voyons ils ne sont plus aussi
agressif
les gens avaient peur de se faire tuer
ou kidnappés par les talibans je n'ai
rien vu de ce genre de mes propres yeux
on dit à la télé ou sur youtube que ça
arrive mais je n'ai pas vu de telles
choses moi-même
la lap s est installée largement dans
kaboul des talibans c'est de montrer
qu'ils ont changé l'émirat islamique
selon leur nom officiel connaît un
problème d'image et pas seulement leur
réputation des a précédé des dizaines de
milliers de personnes ont fui kaboul et
le pays elle ne tenait pas à vérifier si
les taliban tiendraient leur promesse d'
amnistie de grâce et de réformes
je n'ai que du mépris pour ceux qui
partent ce sont les cerveaux les jeunes
comment le pays peut-il se remettre et
avancés s'ils s'en vont tous
voilà pourquoi ils font un tel effort de
relations publiques pourquoi ils
laissent les médias étrangers filmé et
discuter avec leurs combattants c'est ce
qu'ils ont fait nous ont laissé entrer
dans leur avant poste afin de filmer
leurs prises de guerre soit office
voici l'un des véhicules hummer des
talibans nous les avons vus sur les
vidéos les orcs nom des centaines de ce
type ainsi que des milliers d'autres
véhicules des milliards de dollars
d'armes de véhicules de chats et même
d'hélicoptères ont été abandonnées par
l'armée afghanes durant leur retraite
résultat les talibans n'ont pas
suffisamment de drapeaux pour les
installer sur leur propre véhicule à
kaboul devant leur ville qu'ils ont
installé un simple tissu blanc pour
symboliser le drapeau blanc de leur
mouvement
la rapide avancée des talibans les a
visiblement épuisée et combattants
dorment peu il y a trop à faire et ils
sont trop peu pour le faire pour
l'instant mais cela n'a pas entamé leur
zèle
nous avons lutté pendant des années pour
l'indépendance de l'afghanistan face aux
américains et nous continuerons à la sab
le mans à combattre les envahisseurs de
plus en plus de gens nous rejoignent
avec le temps notre frère a perdu sa
jambe dans le combat mais nous sommes
avec lui et il est avec nous nous ne
sommes pas fatigués nous ne nous
fatiguerons jamais
les talibans ont étudié les usages du
monde la manière forte le zèle et le
fanatisme c'est bien pour les
combattants mais les leaders ont besoin
de garder les idées claires voilà
pourquoi ils font preuve de plus de
réserves alors que les têtes brûlées
sont tenus en laisse par des combattants
plus vieux et plus expérimenté
chez les citoyens afghans qui ont
travaillé et coopérer avec les forces
américaines et européennes qui ont
traduit pour eux mais aussi pour leurs
ambassades pour leur organisation qui
travaillaient ici il existe chez tous
ces gens la conviction absolue que cela
va se produire que vous allez tuer tous
ceux qui étaient contre les talibans
maintenant que vous êtes au pouvoir est
ce le cas
bien sûr que nous ne les avons pas mais
s'ils veulent partir ils peuvent partir
ils peuvent aller en amérique mais ils
ne seront pas loyaux pour autant ce sont
des traîtres mais l'émirat y va tous là
a ordonné de ne pas les toucher ils font
l'objet d'une amnistie et nous ne les
toucheront donc pas ceux qui disent que
nous l'étions menthe
les talibans n'ont pas réellement été
fidèles à leur parole il y a eu un
certain nombre d'exécutions de meurtre
de ce qu'ils aidaient les forces
étrangères s'opposait aux talibans après
plusieurs jours ici à kaboul il devient
évident que les talibans font face à un
énorme manque d'effectif leurs
combattants travail trop et sont sous
pression pourtant de toute évidence ces
nouveaux talibans sont là pour gagner je
reprends l'expression les coeurs et les
esprits d argan plutôt que de les briser
comme leur effet les talibans de jadis
reste encore à voir s'ils sont vraiment
et qu'elle relevons désormais jouer les
talibans dans le pays écouter l'analyse
de pierre connaissaît les anciens hauts
fonctionnaires et spécialiste des
questions stratégiques internationales
le bilan de l'opération occidentale est
dramatique donc on a encouragé la
corruption et les talibans apparaît si
vous voulez comme avec deux
caractéristiques d'abord ils vont enfin
établir la paix c'était déjà l'heure
leur premier triomphe lors de leur
premier passage au pouvoir il a vérifié
à réduire les chefs de guerre à quasi
rien donc ils sont allés à part attendre
les faiseurs de paix est évidemment
probable comme des hommes de lutte
contre la corruption donc ils ont deux
atouts en main et qui fait qu'ils
peuvent diriger ce pays maintenant la
situation d'aisé désertant sera de toute
façon dramatique donc il faut faire
attention à ce qu'ils voulaient pas
mélanger tous les problèmes la
discussion avec les talibans va
probablement se fait se faire sur la
question de la reprise de l'aide
économique il est conditionné par un
certain nombre d'avancées est-ce que ce
dialogue sera possible ou pas c'est très
difficile de le savoir l'idée d'une safe
zone rejetée par les talibans emmanuel
macron devait la défendre demain devant
l'onu il s'agirait en fait d'une zone
protégée proposé avec le royaume uni le
but est de faciliter les opérations
humanitaires et notamment de continuer
les évacuations pour les demandeurs
d'asile afghans mais pour soi chahine le
porte-parole du bureau politique des
talibans qui réagissait auprès de nos
confrères de france info
cette zone n'est pas nécessaire selon
lui les afghans pourront librement en
voyage et après le 31 août je vous
rappelle que les opérations françaises
d'évacuation de civils afghans se sont
achevées vendredi soir tout comme celle
du royaume uni londres qui a fermé les
portes de son ambassade en afghanistan
le ministère des affaires étrangères
l'armée les forces de sécurité
frontalière ont réalisé une tâche
exceptionnel et intense en travaillant
ensemble pour mettre plus de 15000
personnes en sécurité en moins de deux
semaines nous devons quitter
l'afghanistan pour le moment et
l'ambassade opèrera depuis le qatar
pendant cette période mais nous
continuerons d'être aux côtés du peuple
afghan vient travail humanitaire
diplomatique et sécuritaire et surtout
nous accueillerons au royaume uni des
afghans et ressortissants britanniques
qui ont encore besoin de notre soutien
ils nous feront pression sur les
talibans qu'il autorise un passage
sécurisé pour ces personnes nous
rouvrirons l'ambassade dès que possible
et nous ferons tout notre possible pour
protéger les acquis de ces vingt
dernières années et surtout nous
aideront le peuple afghan à atteindre la
paix et la sécurité qu'il mérite
parmi les afghans qui n'ont pas pu
quitter le pays d'anciens soldats
auxiliaires ou interprètes qui ont
travaillé avec les forces étrangères
selon un rapport d'experts de l'onu ils
sont recherchés par les talibans qui les
considèrent comme des traîtres
résultat ces afghans craignent pour leur
vie même si les insurgés ont annoncé
qu'il n'y aurait pas de représailles
voyez le témoignage de mamad nassim aux
boules avec sa famille il a trouvé
refuge dans le nord du pays et la deux
masculine
muhammad nasim ghoul père de deux
enfants s'est installé à my man à la
capitale provinciale du nord du pays
juste après la prise de pouvoir des
talibans
ici ils tentent de construire une
nouvelle vie difficile pour cet ancien
soldat qui a participé à des missions de
l'otan pendant des années
les forces spéciales était un bloc
opérationnel l'ensemble du personnel le
personnel de bureau un centre notre
équipe y travailler j'ai contribué à de
nombreuses missions à tadao almar des
quasars j'ai participé à des missions
dans ses différents districts ainsi que
dans la province de faryab il y avait
des opérations d'envergure qui ont
également lorsque les forces de police
d'autres groupes avaient besoin d'être
il demande l aide des forces spéciales
et nous les aidions aujourd'hui sans
emploi mohamed nassim ghoul craint pour
l'avenir du pays et de sa famille
la plus grande préoccupation ce sont mes
enfants si ce gouvernement continue
comme ça la situation restera désespérée
si les employés du gouvernement ne
retourne pas au travail l'avenir du pays
sera critique nous sommes inquiet pour
l'avenir de nos enfants sur la façon
dont il pourra s'éclaircir sans promesse
d'évolution et avec le chômage pour
l'instant nous sommes assignés à
résidence et nos enfants ne reçoivent
plus aucune éducation actuellement les
universités et des écoles sont fermées
et nous sommes inquiets pour nos enfants
des milliers de personnes tentent de
fuir l'afghanistan depuis la prise de
pouvoir des talibans le 15 août perçus
comme des traîtres ces soldats qui ont
collaboré avec les armées étrangères
sont directement dans le viseur des
talibans en 1996 lors de la prise de
kaboul par les insurgés
un grand nombre de militaires avait été
réprimé par l'émirat islamique
et malina emmanuel macron poursuit à sa
visite en irak il est allé ce matin à la
rencontre des chrétiens à mossoul dans
une église en en reconstruction une
journée destinée à témoigner je cite son
respect à toutes les communautés
irakiennes mossoul ville dévastée lors
de sa reprise 22 pt islamique en 2017 le
président français a également rencontré
les dirigeants du kurdistan irakien fer
de lance des combats contre des ch la
lutte contre le terrorisme et la
stabilité de la région est au coeur de
cette visite de deux jours je vous
propose d'écouter emmanuel m'a plu
la situation reste très difficile et
très fragile il ya encore des groupes
terroristes mais je crois que notre rôle
aux côtés du gouvernement irakien et des
autorités c'est d'essayer de prévenir
l'écossé que ça ne se reproduise pas et
pourquoi tout ça était devenu parce
qu'il avait beaucoup de corruption il
faut aider à lutter contre la corruption
parce qu'ils avaient plus de projets
économiques et donc notre rôle
modestement aux côtés des autorités
c'est d'aider à ascq et des emplois pour
que la jeunesse et des espoirs et ne
rejoignent pas des projets de misère etc
d'aidé à l'éducation et à la
connaissance entre les les cultures et
les religions pour le respect et c'est
aussi pour ça que ce à travers ces
visites mais les projets que la france
porte on reconstruit pas simplement des
pierres mais on reconstruit la capacité
de femmes et d'hommes qui croient dans
un dieu
mais qui veulent aussi apprendre et
enseigner la paix
actualité au proche orient israël a
bombardé à des sites du hamas dans la
bande de gaza d'après l'armée
israélienne
plusieurs centaines de palestiniens
s'étaient rassemblés près de la
frontière lançant des explosifs depuis
l'enclavé palestinienne des
manifestations pour dénoncer les
restrictions imposées par l'état hébreu
à leur territoire le point avec amaya
soubré et médias ski fis
à l'aide de fumigènes et d'explosifs les
palestiniens dirigent leurs tirs vers
les forces de l'ordre israéliennes
des tensions qui persistent depuis
plusieurs jours
après que le temps est passé et que les
atermoiements de l'ennemi israélien et
notre patience était à bout nous avons
décidé que la missio nist ne bénéficiera
pas du calme si le siège israélien sur
la bande de gaza n'est pas levé
des ballons incendiaires ont également
été envoyés vers israël la réaction de
l'état hébreu ne s'est pas fait attendre
le premier ministre naftali bennett a
directement incriminé le hamas ait
annoncé que l'armée israélienne avait
visé un entrepôt du groupe armé
palestinien tôt ce dimanche ainsi que
l'entrée d'un tunnel adjacent à la ville
de jabalya
en ce qui concerne gaza pendant la nuit
les forces de défense israéliennes ont
attaqué à gaza en réponse au gonflement
des ballons comme je l ai déjà dit nous
opérons à gaza en fonction de notre
intérêt ce qui me concerne l'adresse des
responsables était et reste celle du
hamas
à damas samedi dernier un jeune
palestinien de 12 ans est décédée après
des tirs de l'armée israélienne lors de
manifestations des tirs qui ont
également blessé une quarantaine de
personnes parmi les gazaouis un membre
des forces de sécurité israéliennes est
par ailleurs toujours dans un état
critique en egypte après avoir été
fermée depuis lundi le point de passage
de rafah limitrophes à gaza a été
rouverte dans les deux sens ce dimanche
une ouverture qui représente l'unique
brèche vers le monde extérieur qui n'est
pas contrôlé par israël à ce jour au
yémen une attaque a fait une trentaine
de morts et plus de 50 blessés dans le
sud du pays des frappes ont touché une
base aérienne près de la ville d'aden
deuxième du pays et capitale provisoire
du gouvernement yéménite l' attaque n'a
pas été revendiquée mais les forces
militaires loyalistes accusent les
rebelles houthi d'en être responsable 30
combattants pro gouvernementaux sont
mort dans lors de cette attaque le bilan
pourrait évoluer les blessés ont été
transportés vers l'hôpital le plus
proche
il est encore des corps sous les
décombres dont certains sont brûlés et
pour d'autres c'est pire encore nous
attendons qu'il soit amené ici pour que
les mesures nécessaires soient prises
nous étions rassemblés à l'intérieur du
hangar après le petit déjeuner nous
avons vu un trône en vol stationnaire et
nous avons essayé de tirer dessus pour
la battre mais nous n'avons pas réussi à
le toucher l'engin survolé et s'est
dirigé directement vers le hangar où il
a tiré deux missiles sur la première
unité
une explosion s'est produite à allah
nahd les deux premiers missiles ont
touché la caserne il y avait plus de 50
personnes à l'intérieur
après 20 minutes un troisième missile a
touché la base
touché la base puis environ 20 minutes
plus tard des drones sont arrivés mais
nous avons pu en toucher 1 beaucoup de
gens ont été tués et blessés
qui succédera à engueuler à merkel en
allemagne la chancelière quittera ses
fonctions à l'issue des élections
législatives du 26 septembre les trois
prétendants au poste s'affrontent ce
soir lors d'un premier grand débat
télévisé
aucun n'a réussi à émerger jusque là
mais pour la première fois depuis 15 ans
le parti social démocrate spd est donné
en tête avec olaf scholz des intentions
de vote devant donc le parti de la cd ou
dans gala merkel mais aussi les
écologistes france risquait beach
c'est un olaf scholz détendu qui se
prête au jeu des selphy à la fin d'un
meeting dans la capitale allemande dans
un sondage publié ce mardi par
l'institut forsa le candidat du parti
social démocrate arrive en tête crédité
de 23% des intentions de vote une
première pour le parti depuis octobre
et c'est plaisant de voir comment les
sondages évolué il est touchant de voir
combien de citoyens me font confiance
pour être le prochain chancelier de la
république fédérale d'allemagne
c'est une fonction difficile et quand
tant de gens disent que vous pouvez le
faire c'est un moment très émouvant pour
moi aussi a refait décrit comme
quelqu'un de peu charismatique au la
fiole 63 ans réussit un plan simple
selon l'hebdomadaire der spiegel être
élu en étant celui qui ressemble plus à
la chancelière ministre des finances et
bi chancelier du gouvernement merkel il
a tiré profit de la pandémie en
débloquant des centaines de milliards
d'euros pour soutenir l'économie du pays
grand h pour les années 2020 grand h
pour l'avenir de notre pays
un avenir des possibles un avenir
meilleur avec plus de respect de bons
emplois et la protection du climat il
est important que chacun sache que cela
ne peut réussir que s'il y a un
gouvernement dirigé par les
sociaux-démocrates
une campagne électorale jusqu'ici sans
faute al'inverse de ses rivaux qui ont
multiplié les bévues armin laschet tu
candidat de la cd ou héritiers légitimes
de la chancelière s'est effondré dans
les sondages film est hilare pendant une
cérémonie d'hommage aux sinistrés des
crues pris en faute de plagiat dans un
livre il n'est crédité que de 22% des
intentions de vote soit le score du
parti le plus bas enregistré depuis
1984 enfin un temps donné favori au
printemps après la désignation de leur
chef de file anna lena bat r block les
versions des pluies à la peine une prime
dont des clarisses un soupçon elle aussi
de plagiat dans son livre de campagne et
un cv enjolivé ont discrédité
déstabiliser la jeune candidat de 40 ans
entraînant une baisse significative de
son parti dans les intentions de vote
et pour françois poule et mathis
journalistes et spécialistes des
institutions européennes les cartes ont
été totalement rebattues dans ces
élections écouter
la tendance qui se dessine c'est plutôt
un effondrement cela pose aussi la
question de la crédibilité de celui qui
était soutenu par angela merkel alors
qu'une majorité faible certes de la cd
ou jugé que ce candidat armin laschet tu
étais un peu trop juste pas assez
compétent par rapport à un autre
candidat qui était jugée plus sérieux
plus conservateurs donc le fait d'avoir
paradoxalement à gauche un candidat
plutôt conservateur alors qu al droite
le candidat a l'air peut-être un peu
plus fort désiste cela rabat bien sûr
des cartes mais ça pose aussi un
problème pour le candidat du spd
car le candidat du spd devra aussi
convaincre son propre parti qui lui est
plus à gauche et qui était assez
exigeants en matière de réformes
sociales alors est-ce que ce candidat du
spd sera rassembler de manière assez
large à la fois son corps mais aussi une
grande partie de l'électorat allemand
c'est la grande question qui va se poser
dans les quatre semaines qui viennent
actualité en france avec cette nouvelle
étape pour le pass sanitaire dès demain
il sera imposé aux salariés qui
travaillent dans des lieux où le qr code
et déjà demandé aux clients les employés
qui refuse de présenter pourront voir
leur contrat de travail suspendu impasse
sanitaire qui continue de mobiliser
contre lui pour le 7e samedi consécutif
près de cent soixante mille personnes se
sont rassemblées hier partout en france
pour exprimer leur mécontentement
retour sur cette journée de mobilisation
avec maxime abers
il est entré en vigueur depuis plus de
deux mois et pourtant le pass sanitaire
anime toujours la colère de certains
français ce samedi 220 manifestations
ont eu lieu dans toute la france ils
étaient quatorze mille cinq cents à
paris ou deux cortèges ont été
particulièrement suivie celui d'abord
initié par florian philippot et les
patriotes
parmi les manifestants des slogans
prônant le retour des libertés la non
vaccination des enfants ou encore la
préférence pour des traitements comme
l'hydro xi chloroquine et français voile
usage ce que c'est que ce pass
sanitaires ils voient que ça n'a rien de
salutaire je sais les politiques de
restriction de liberté que beaucoup de
pays sont en train de s'en débarrasser
est-ce qu'on avait promis le tout
vaccinal les restes sont divertis elle
passa les terres étant la clé ça même ça
ne fonctionne pas et on obtiendra à la
fin de cette loi de la honte la fin du
pass de là entre autres défiler dans les
rues de la capitale un rassemblement
apolitique organisé par des gilets
jaunes tout de blanc vêtus et mobiliser
contre l'obligation vaccinale des
soignants on soutient évidemment les
soignants compte cette obligation
qu'elle est on dénonce le l'instauration
se passe sanitaire qu'on considère comme
étant vraiment le summum du contrôle des
citoyens on est en pleine dictature
sanitaire masqué alors parce qu'on
instrumentalise la peur de ce virus dont
on se sert de la peur une obligation
vaccinale qui entre en vigueur le 15
septembre à partir de cette date les
soignants s'exposeront à des sanctions
peu importe pour certains c'est la
liberté avant tout aujourd'hui
infirmier et demain je sais pas ce que
je
vais faire parce que je ne compte pas me
faire vacciner et je le fais pour moi
mais pour la population pour les gens
qui sont vaccinées aussi notre ami ne
vaut pas vivre sans mon salaire mais mon
choix est plus important et c'est une
décision commune je le vis très mal ça a
été très compliqué pour moi parce que je
j'ai fait ce choix mais du jour au
lendemain j'ai beaucoup pleuré parce que
c'est toute une vie qui s'arrête il est
aujourd'hui je sais même pas ce que je
vais faire avec 15000 manifestants de
moins que la semaine précédente
le mouvement semble perdre de l'ampleur
selon un sondage publié lundi dernier
une large majorité des français se
prononcent est d'ailleurs contre la
mobilisation de ces dernières semaines
de quoi confirmer olivier véran dans ses
propos le ministre de la santé affirmait
jeudi que les réticences étaient en
train de tomber des propos à nuancer
puisque les nouvelles vaccination en
france stagne autour de 140 mille
injection de premières doses par jour
toujours selon le ministre de la santé
le pass sanitaire pourrait être lui
prolonger au delà du 15 novembre la
limite fixée par la loi
autorités et services de renseignement
craignent une radicalisation du
mouvement anti passe dès septembre les
organisateurs présent à paris ont en
tout cas invité à de nouveaux
rassemblements dès le 4 septembre
prochain
et comment expliquer que le mouvement
perdure tout l'été pourquoi tant de
colère contre ce pas sanitaire le
gouvernement peut-il plier gilles
casanova expert en stratégie et
communication et stéphane rozès
politologue ont donné leur avis sur
cette question
la chose sur laquelle ils devraient
réfléchir c'est glee l'idée de ce
passeport à point pour composer la vie
sociale c'est sans lien avec la santé ça
pourrait être demain attribué à un autre
sujet et ça a été quelque chose
présenté par les consultants américains
notamment de mckinsey qui ont travaillé
avec les autorités chinoises sur le
crédit social c'est-à-dire ce dispositif
qui fait que si vous vous comportez bien
selon le gouvernement chinois vous
pouvez voyager assez loin sinon vous
êtes à peu près confiné chez vous et
indépendamment de questions sanitaires
et là on est dans la même question et
c'est celle qui est explosive qui fait
que le mouvement auquel on assiste
rassemble des gens de toutes les
catégories sociales le gouvernement les
observateurs
mieux
enregistré qu'il y avait une minorité
importante
qui s'exprimait contre le pass sanitaire
mid ou l'obligation et l'obligation
vaccinale c'est une donnée maintenant
intégrée
du point de vue du gouvernement ou ne
vois pas qui de change
d'attitude et de politique sanitaire
sans inquiéter le climat autour de ces
questions n'est pas bonnes donc en
termes de morale pour le pays tout cela
n'est pas une bonne affaire mais il n'y
a au fond des sujets d'inquiétudes
sanitaires
économiques sociaux
il y à une rentrée politique
qui est au fond l'inquiétude et à eux
partout et le gouvernement tente de
montrer ils maîtrisent une situation
encore instable ou qui rend la plupart
des personnes inquiètes dans là quand on
espère en tenir les différentes
contraintes au quotidien et c'est la fin
de cette édition merci à vous d'avoir
suivi on se retrouve dans une trentaine
de minutes pour un nouveau journal à
tout à l'heure
[Musique]
y'a pas une façon plus une pauvre de
défendre un système que de dire qu'il
est moins pire qu'un autre la table
accepté